these people are being dropped off at
the end of a lonely country road in
upstate New York
they've come here to flee America my
visa expired I can't come back I have no
choice
well I still
[Music]
anyhow please please sir my country has
wars over there I don't have country to
go to afraid unsure they're waiting to
hear these words if you're Kasich if
we're gonna have to arrest you for you
to be obvious and then you'll be
transferred to the immigration officer
decision made
picking their way past abandoned luggage
and a baby's pram it's a few short steps
to Canada and a chance to become a
refugee there the next morning it
happens again this time it's three men
from Turkey can you tell me why you're
leaving sir I live in English they show
us letters explaining why they want to
leave asylum yeah you were a teacher
yeah I am a teacher history teacher
it says here Canada helps refugees and
gives them opportunity to live as human
beings without any fear why not stay in
America because the Trump because Donald
Trump
minutes after the men cross u.s. Border
Patrol arrives there have been reports
of undocumented people being caught and
deported to home countries before they
have chance to get over the line if that
was the intention
this time the officers too late
do you have any weapons on you anything
sharpening the many being detained by
the Canadian police is actually the aim
an agreement between the US and Canada
prevents people from either country
seeking refugee status in the other but
that law doesn't apply at unofficial
points of entry and since Donald Trump
road to power on a wave of populist
anti-immigrant sentiment thousands have
crossed this way definitely seeing those
family crossing the border
you know we touched somewhere our hearts
where all most of us are for and mothers
so the approach is going to be softer
after a background check
most people are released and given
access to housing schools emergency
health care and work permits while they
await immigration hearings the US and
Canada may be neighbors but right now
they're separated by much more than this
vast border running through the
wilderness
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News at the u.s.
Canadian border